[Music]
American parenting really changed in the
1990s when I'm talking about the book I
go around the country I ask audiences at
what age were you let out at what age
could you go outside and play with your
friends with no adults supervising and I
say only people over 40 what's your
answer call it out and it's five seven
eight six five seven it's always five to
eight that's what we always did between
five and eight kids could go outside
without an adult they get in arguments
they would they would play games they
would make rules they were independent
they got years and years of practicing
independence then I say just people
under 25 what year were you let out
twelve fourteen thirteen sixteen nobody
says ten are younger in the 1990s as the
crime rate was plummeting as American
life was getting safer and safer
Americans freaked out and thought that
if they take their eyes off their
children that children will be abducted
now this goes back the fear was stoked
by cable TV in the 1980s there were a
few high-profile abductions but it's not
until the 1990s that we really start
locking kids up and saying you cannot be
outside until you're 14 or 15 we took
this essential period of childhood for
about eight to twelve when kids
throughout history have practiced
independence have gotten into adventures
have made rafts and floated down the
Mississippi River
we took that period and said you don't
get to practice independence until it's
too late until that period is over now a
couple years before you go to college
now you can go outside oh okay go off to
college and a lot of them are not ready
they're just not used to being
independent when they get to college
they need more help they're asking
adults for more help protect me from
this punish him for saying that protect
me from that book there's a very sharp
change with kids were born in 1995 and
afterwards surprisingly sharp gene
twangy in her book I Jen analyzes
surveys of behavior of time use and
beginning with kids born in 1995 they
spend a lot less time going out with
friends they don't get a driver's
license as often they don't drink as
much they don't go out on dates they
don't work for money as much what are
they doing there's
spending a lot more time sitting on
their beds with their devices
interacting that way these are the first
kids who got social media when they were
13 roughly they were subjected to much
more anti bullying content in their
schools much more adult supervision they
were raised in the years after 9/11 they
were they were given much less recess
and free play with No Child Left Behind
there was much more testing pushed down
into earlier grades we don't know if
this is for sure the reason but they
seem to have more difficulty working out
problems on their own the most common
thing I hear is that members of Gen Z if
they overhear a joke if they overhear
someone say something they'll they'll
get offended and then they'll go
straight to HR they go straight to
somebody to file a complaint where
previous generations would have either
just shaking it off and just said you
know jerk or asshole or whatever I think
there are a couple things we can say one
is is you have to take charge of device
use in social media we don't know for
sure but it looks like a two-hour limit
per day is probably a good idea keeping
kids off of social media as long as
possible is a good idea it's very hard
to do this as one parent when your kids
friends are not limited so you've got to
talk to your kids friends and all have a
common front all have a common policy
then go to the schools schools can solve
these problems collectively in ways that
individual parents cannot outside of
school go to let grow org an
organization a wonderful new
organization started by leonora skin AZ
who wrote the book free-range kids
she became famous as America's worst mom
because in 2009 she let her
nine-year-old son ride the New York City
Subway not only did he survive he was
thrilled he felt he'd learned something
he felt he could go out into the world
give childhood back to kids so that they
do what they most need to do which is
develop the skills of being an
independent adult remember that the job
of a parent is to work him or herself
out of a job